nous ne savons toujours pas comment nous appeler
Pogo artistes jumper blasters
[Musique]
un peu comme les nerds ou les Geeks of
Action Sports et quel genre de bien avec
ça
ils pensent que nous sommes des punks ils pensent que nous sommes
fous et nous sommes  un peu fou mais
quelque chose
est les championnats du monde de pogo
coller trois deux un Pogo c'est à peu
près tous les meilleurs autocollants Pogo extrêmes
du monde se réunissent
oh nous sommes
sur le point de commencer Wilkinsburg êtes-vous
prêt
je suis prêt
[Musique]
trois secondes  restent excellents les
athlètes sur deux critères, le premier
est la compétence qui est la difficulté des
figures, mais aussi la variation de l'autre
moitié du score. Style à quel point
les figures sont-elles
bonnes.  en partie
étranger,
je veux dire que le monde du pogo n'est qu'une
collection de beaux
individus bizarres, nous sommes tous juste des enfants uniques
qui ne savaient pas où mettre notre énergie
et pour une raison quelconque, le destin,
quel que soit le sort qui a amené des pogo sticks dans notre
orbite et nous venons de recevoir  obsédé par ça
et puis nous nous sommes tous réunis
votre vie
[Musique]
54 dans un bloc-notes boulet de canon dans un
front flip
Tom Smith du septuple
champion du monde
vous savez que vous pensez aux grands athlètes
un Tom Brady ou Michael Jordan Tony Hawk
peu importe comme ils viennent  j'ai cet
instinct de tueur et je n'en ai pas beaucoup
mais en même temps
c'est vraiment devenu cette chose où d'
une manière ou d'une autre, année après année, il
livre toujours je l'ai entendu dire qu'il veut 10
années de suite Je suis juste au monde
enregistrer à 12 pieds au-dessus de la barre dans un pogo
stick
étranger,
nous avons tendance à avoir des similitudes
comme les gens que Pogo nous sommes en
quelque sorte tous liés au TDAH euh à peu près
en partant de bas en haut j'ai cassé
la plupart des choses mes orteils
oh craque ma hanche mes deux rotules
craquent ma côte je me suis cassé les deux
chevilles probablement quatre fois au total j'ai
eu 14 points de suture sur ma paupière mes
vertèbres T1 m'ont fracturé la joue
discussions je me suis cassé le nez cinq
fois
[Musique  ]
oui c'est dangereux oui c'est illogique
et stupide
mais ce sont toutes les raisons si vous
les retournez pourquoi c'est si beau et si
poétique parce que le danger élève
tout
War runs
[Music]
Tyler Phillips est juste un
mec génial génial nous voyons ces éléments
de ce feu en lui qui n'a pas
nécessairement été là, donc je suis un peu
intéressé par la façon dont cela se joue ici et peut-
être que quelque chose clique et
peut-être qu'il est une sorte de cheval noir
beaucoup de choses techniques intéressantes que
les autres ne font pas  et ça a l'air
bien et cool comme ce mec est vraiment
cool
et Conor Kellogg est le prodige de
Pogo en ce moment, il n'a que 19 ans, il
a toutes ces capacités, j'espère que c'est
l'année où peut-être qu'il
surmonte en quelque sorte sa jeunesse
forte géniale lourde
alors  s'il est réellement capable de tout mettre
ensemble et de passer à l'étape suivante
sur le plan intellectuel, je pense qu'il
peut très bien être finalement stupide
45 secondes oh une [ __ ] dans ce Windex oh
mon Dieu qui est si difficile Hunter avec
le Bruce Lee dans  un double Loops dans un
boulet de canon sans pied dans un stick flip
dans un stick flip et nous sommes de retour avec
cette bouche
wow
quel [ __ ] de Jam mon mot
tous les grands concurrents de l'air veulent
venir ici nous annoncerons le top 10
en mouvement  jusqu'à la troisième place votre
champion en titre Dalton Smith
81.83
se qualifiant en deuxième Connor Kellogg et
se qualifiant à la première place M. Tyler
Phillips
[Musique]
Je pensais que c'était des qualifications vraiment excitantes
cette année, il y a vraiment beaucoup de monde
en haut du classement il y a peu de
surprise à voir Tyler  dans les premiers [ __ ] de
chiens malades
tu sais Connor je pense que nous nous attendons tous à
une vraie menace félicitations pour tout
ton succès
tu sais Dalton je pense secrètement qu'il
aime en quelque sorte ne pas être tout à fait lui en premier c'est
comme si je suis tombé cette première fois alors j'étais
tellement le  la partie la plus difficile comme il a besoin de
cette pression ou je veux dire qu'il est un
mec sournois comme peut-être qu'il
laisse intentionnellement tout le monde se reposer et ne
met pas la pression jusqu'à la toute
fin s'il y avait des paris sur Pogo
palooza qui, pour autant que je sache, il n'y a
pas moi  pense qu'il serait toujours le favori par excellence,
voici comment fonctionne la finale chaque athlète
dure 60 secondes trois fois le
score le plus élevé sera conservé les deux
autres seront abandonnés, donc il s'agit vraiment
d'obtenir cette course parfaite une
autre chose que les hommes signifient  si vos pieds
touchent le sol si vous ne prêtez pas de
tour ou si vous tombez cela compte comme des
points négatifs donc essentiellement si vous
renflouer vous ne pouvez pas gagner
Leslie comment vous sentez-vous je me sens
prêt à partir je me sens excité je  Je ne
sais pas si le public est prêt bien
qu'étranger
huit années de suite
[Musique]
donc vous verrez même parfois si quelqu'un
tombe tôt, il sera juste comme hé je vais l'
arrêter économiser mon énergie essayer pour l'un
des  mes derniers morceaux
[Musique]
Bales blessent vraiment ces gars la porte
grande ouverte pour que Connor passe à la première
place ici
Connor es-tu prêt Connor Kellogg seulement
19 ans n'a pas peur de l'expérience
mais il a le cœur il a la
confiance
mon plus grand  la faiblesse est probablement euh la
facilité avec laquelle je suis intimidé en
regardant ces
backflips obliques obliques
35. Je suis toujours compétitif, donc je
cherche à détrôner Dalton cette année
comment allez-vous faire ça euh je
vais grand
en avant
corps autour oh
il va l'appeler lors de cette première course
ouais il se rend compte qu'il est dans la
zone Bell Tyler es-tu prêt
non
et il est prêt alors nous commençons dans trois deux
un Pogo
j'ai appris à creuser sur cette
plaque de mort que j'ai été  m'entraînant assez
dur pour cette compétition cette année, j'ai
été très silencieux sur les réseaux sociaux à
ce sujet et euh j'essaie de m'en débarrasser
j'ai l'impression que nous avons besoin d'un
coup de pied en ciseaux l'après-midi Ariel il le colle ils
étaient à deepthro et Dalton  ce serait un
gros problème
[Applaudissements]
Course sans faille Je pense qu'il ne fait aucun doute que cela le
placera en tête du classement le
score le plus élevé pour chaque athlète
compte beaucoup de place pour l'amélioration Je
ne voulais pas aimer la caution et ensuite être
comme  alors tu dois y penser
partout Tu vas perdre maintenant tout ce que tu peux
faire est d'améliorer ça assez
je veux dire comment tu escalades ce mec je
ne sais même pas si
je peux en quelque sorte si le crapaud
n'avait pas cette caution  il serait sur le
podium en ce moment
il dort la confiance respire la
confiance a même des ailes sur ses casques
Dalton Smith veut un meilleur buteur ceci
et puis une autre occasion de défendre
sa couronne pour la huitième année nous verrons
si cela se produit Dalton êtes-vous prêt  trois
deux un Pogo
[Music]
et je pense que c'est une caution, ça
ressemble à 45 secondes
d'attente
[Music]
attendez
un énorme combo cinq
quatre trois est suffisant pour quelques pilules un
et un Mandy ouais
tu sais je pense que ça va
l'émouvoir  près du podium peut-être pas tout à fait sur
le podium selon la façon dont les juges le
marquent cette année Tyler Kellogg ils
réussissent vraiment tous les
trucs ils sont cohérents donc je
transpire un peu et euh ça
me rend nerveux je veux  fais quelque chose d'énorme
pour suivre le rythme mais euh
ouais je veux juste atterrir
cette course propre alors essaie juste de
la garder calme pour l'instant
merci
[Music]
à la boîte
oh ça ne colle pas
oh  j'essaie de faire une plante de pied dans une
raclette C Stitch une deuxième caution des histoires
au point que Connor s'éloigne humblement
euh qui l'a vraiment mangé là-haut, il
pense à ce qu'il va faire dans
ce prochain trajet
Je craque toujours le dernier jour comme  ça
me touche plus que n'importe quel autre père
Dom a cette pension pour ne pas avoir eu une
bonne première ou deuxième manche et vous savez que
quelqu'un pense qu'il est assis en première
place mais ils ne peuvent jamais se reposer tranquillement jusqu'à ce que
Dalton ait sa troisième manche et euh ils
havre  Je ne me suis pas reposé facilement au cours des sept dernières
années
[Applaudissements]
50 secondes attaquées sans aide
45 secondes
montrant que la compétence technique
est une balle trois
deux un
étranger
[Musique]
devient obsolète et c'est incroyable d'être
le champion et j'ai adoré tenir
le niveau de compétence est si élevé depuis si longtemps et
je le ferai toujours, mais il est préférable de continuer à
avancer voir ce que fait le journal ouais,
il est la scène trop grande pour ce jeune de 19 ans,
nous sommes sur le point de savoir s'il peut
livrer et accomplir la prophétie  du
journal devenant le meilleur au monde
Wilkinsburg êtes-vous prêt
tellement attention
un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je pense que je
pense que je ne veux pas être nos juges
en ce moment
Connor Kellogg vient de marquer un 80
8.17
est passé à la première place Tyler's maintenant  en
quelques secondes, il a garanti une place sur le
podium la quête la question est peut-il
récupérer cet objectif la porte est ouverte ici
Wilkinsburg êtes-vous prêt pour la dernière
manche de Big Air 2022.
[Applaudissements]
oh ouais
quatre trois
mots
c'était une compétition incroyable
encore une salve d'applaudissements pour tous les
concurrents euh je sens l'
adrénaline descendre un peu de
douleur mais beaucoup d'amour pour le
sport la communauté et tous mes garçons
palooza c'était un succès cette année
tout dépend s'il vous plait  descendez attendez que
les juges obtiennent notre source finale en
ce que nous annoncerons votre gagnant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] a
obtenu ses sept titres et ensuite il a pris la
septième place Je ne peux pas croire que Dalton
ne soit pas sur le podium
après sa dernière course Tyler Phillips  a obtenu
un 87 à la deuxième place, donc la deuxième place à
Tyler, cela signifie que vous êtes un gagnant
or mais
c'est la bûche
c'était les bûches ici allons-y nous sommes tous de
très bons amis parce que c'est
comme une petite communauté et c'est juste
ce qui le rend vraiment spécial pour nous
parce que c'est comme si nous étions les seules personnes
au monde à faire ça  merde, ça
va juste les illuminer en gagnant et euh faire
quelque chose dont tu es fier te fait te
sentir électrique c'est ce que je ressens depuis si
longtemps encore alors j'espère que tous ces enfants
commenceront à comprendre tout ce que
j'aime prendre de pogo
[  Musique]
étranger
[Musique]